الزفاف الملكي الاردني عروس الحلاني خطوبه
ندين نسيب ن جيم وولاده طفل رابع ل
الباتشينو اليكم بعض ابرز الاحداث السعيده
التي عاشها مشاهير عرب وعالميون في
[موسيقى]
2023 الاول من حزيران يونيو
2023 تاريخ سيبقى في ذاكره الاردنيين
طويلا عنوانا للبساطه والجمال والاناقه
الملكيه والعادات الاصيله يوم شهدت فيه
عمان مراسم الزفاف الملكي لولي عهد الاردن
الامير الحسين بن عبد الله الثاني
والاميره رجوى الحسين وحضره العديد من
ملوك وامراء العالم الذين شاركوا العاهل
الاردني والملكه رانيا العبد الله فرحتهم
بالزفاف الملكي
اردنيه
سعوديه اردنيه
سعوديه وقبل الزفاف الملكي الاردني اتجهت
الانظار في مارس اذار 2023 الى بيت الاردن
الذي شهد عقد قران وزفاف ابنه العاهل
الاردني الاميره ايمان في مراسم ارتسمت
بالاناقه والبساطه على دربك على دارك خطوه
وخطوه
[موسيقى]
مشي عربيا ايضا حقق زفاف عروس الحلان
مريتا عاصي الحلاني وكميل ابي خليل تفاعلا
كبيرا على منصات التواصل في العام 2023 مع
انتشار الكثير من الصور ومقاطع الفيديو
للحدث السعيد قدم كميل ل ماريتا عرض
الزواج في باريس وعقدا قرانهما وتبادلا
عهود الحب في ابو ظبي واحتفلا بزفافهما في
مزرعه والدها الفنان عاصي الحلاني بمنطقه
البقاع
اللبنانيه العروس زفوها
وع
وفي عيد ميلادها حظيت ندين ن سيبن جيم
بلحظات رومانسيه قدم فيها حبيبها عرض
الزواج لنجمه اللبنانيه وسط احتفاء
الحاضرين لتعلن لاحقا خبر خطوبتها رسميا
الذي حقق تفاعلا كبيرا على منصات التواصل
في العالم
العربي كما تفاعل رواد منصات التواصل على
نطاق واسع في 2023 مع صور حفل زفاف النجم
الجزائري لنادي اه جده السعودي رياض محرز
على عارضه الازياء البريطانيه تيلور ورد
والذي اقيم في العاصمه
البريطانيه ومن الاحداث السعيده التي
عاشها مشاهير عرب وعالميون في العام
2023 ولاده الطفل الاول لثنائي الفني
المصري ايمي سمير غانم وحسن الرداد كما
اعلن المتحدث باسم لينزي لوهان وزوجها رجل
الاعمال الاماراتي الامريكي بدر شماس
انهما رزقا بمولودهما الاول لؤي وذلك بعد
عام على اعلان زواجهما رسميا وتفاعل
متابعوا منصات التواصل على نطاق واسع
عالميا مع خبر ولاده رابع اولاد الممثل
الباتشينو البالغ من العمر 83 عاما من
صديقته نور الفلاح التي تصغره ب 54 عاما
تقريبا وبعد اشهر قليله على ولاده طفلهما
اعلنت نور انفصالها عن النجم
العالمي